has any of the like super ogs uh from
like kind of the whole era before you
and two errors probably before you
whether it's like Royce Big Sean M have
they tapped in with what you're doing I
mean I just Big Sean just made my mom a
day last night he just shout out to Big
Sean he made my mom a day talking to my
mama Big Sean was humble when I met him
too when I he um I I asked him can I
call my mama on the phone and he talked
to her on the phone oh [__] you talked
to my mama oh so you're in the studio
with Sean last night oh [__] he talked
to my mama on the phone
as fire
he made my day like he just made my mom
that was like a humbling experience like
that just was crazy like I was just so
happy he don't even know how happy he
just made me he made my day like a kid
at a candy store your mom's just like
did she expect it when you FaceTiming no
she just answered I I um facetimed when
I was with Chris Brown too he made my my
sister's day like they just they don't
even know they think like I'm just a
rapper and I'm really fanned out I just
don't act like it but I'll be fanned out
see what Shawn did you work on any music
last night no but we um we gonna get
together probably this weekend doing
something gotta be crazy what about
Eminem I haven't I've never seen Eminem
I do want to do some music with Eminem
that'd be fine like I never seen Eminem
but I know he's big for our culture like
everything that he did
um and I think
um the disconnect between Eminem and a
lot of artists from Detroit now is that
he's not a street guy you feel me yeah
he's I mean he's the most successful
rapper ever ever he's disconnected from
the street because he's not in the
streets yeah I mean he's a yeah for sure
and he doesn't owe anybody anything like
I feel like during his era he did a lot
to try to help what was happening now
I'm not sure it's his job when it comes
to like that trick trick Royce and
Autumn right that was his error he
helped his records with trick trick
Royce I mean the D12 guys uh I'm trying
to think if there's any
I mean then there was that whole other
side of Detroit that's like Village and
Jay Dilla and that's like saying Lil
Wayne got to go to New Orleans and work
where every artist comes from the world
hey that is kind of true because I feel
like the Detroit artists be giving
Eminem hell sometimes they do and then
and artists in New Orleans ain't giving
away in hell because he you know that's
yeah I mean look Eminem is one of the
greatest of all time I mean everybody
want to be successful so bad but you
gotta understand that Eminem wouldn't
even sound right on a lot of songs from
Detroit if you just if you yeah if you
put Eminem on some of these records it'd
probably sound it'd suck
I'm just being real because Eminem We a
lot of people don't have real lyrical
content from Detroit we more of a Vibe
right and I feel like a lot of people
um the flow wouldn't even match like
when it comes to putting together
records I've been especially like the
BPM level I'm like I don't know how
Eminem would sound on like a Detroit
beat like I don't like I just don't know
if I want to I don't know I don't think
anybody wants to hear that respectfully
yeah yeah so I don't think nobody wants
to hear that at all for real you guys
working together to be crazy maybe you
go do some [__] like you be like yo I I
went in on this end this is I did this
with you in mind now I had to sit there
and and write for like a week yeah and
then
um get my flow right and be like yeah I
got this for you like I asked Big Sean
that last night like did he ever
um go into it like I'm about to chew
these guys up but he like
the records he been on like his biggest
records with people he did a song left
for open verse and he didn't know who
was getting on it and then so if they
end up going in that's he's not gonna go
back and change his [__] because that's
kind of against rapper rules you know
yeah for sure so
I have to prepare for that though that's
still am are you currently are you
writing stuff down when you have an idea
are you just straight punching in like
what are you I'm doing both yeah I gotta
be for me to write to it I gotta
extremely love to be like like you gotta
have to beat ahead of time but if you're
driving around you think of a bar you're
gonna make a note of it for sure yeah
for sure because a lot some bars you
just can't you can't waste them you
can't forget him you can't forget that
for sure J Cole current
minority owner of the Hornets I'm sure
you've seen do you have any aspirations
to one day be a minority owner for sure
yeah heck yeah
what first thing make the pizzas five
dollars no the free pizza free pizza
when you come in the arena well if you
go to Little Caesars and you're not
getting the extra mostest like the extra
cheese extra pepperoni it's for the
extra Buck you're [__] up by the way
now that you're like traveling the
country
can we have an honest conversation about
yeah
the food in Detroit
is better than everywhere in the country
I mean that's a bold face lie where you
think you think Cali got better oh sure
I think listen I love Detroit when I was
there but I went to like four different
Coney spots bro that's that's why who
sent you the Coney
people in Detroit only eat cognac Mickey
D's on eight mile by truth terrible
place you were supposed to go to Zorba's
I went to the one I went to the one in
that that Sada took me to which is his
spot that might have been that it's like
in the red zone or wherever on the east
side no you're supposed to go to zorbas
on the east side and if you're on the
west side you're supposed to go to L
George's but that's just Coney's people
only eat Coney at two o'clock in the
morning now we did have
a fake I wouldn't say fake
uh baby Tron took us to a place that was
kind of like Raising Cane's you ain't go
to the Burger trip
and the best thing I ate though was a
burger that Juan got me you wouldn't go
to the Burger trip Burger truck did you
go to Sweetwater no Burger truck I went
to the pancake place though the
breakfast spot everyone talks about that
[__] was gas did you go to Mason's no
Midwest Grill did you go to somebody
auntie in the backyard on the grill
you messing up bro you got have you been
to a taco truck in L.A yes
and got me some uh horchata
they're gonna get the [__] pot store
bro they gotta shave the meat off of the
thing onto the tank you think that's
better than everything in Detroit of
course no you gotta go through Detroit
with me also best food I had outside of
the burger one got me was definitely the
food court Asian food at MGM Grand
you gotta go through Detroit with me I'm
gonna do it I'm gonna show you how to
eat in Detroit okay hi do you guys ever
go over to Canada
I'm a fella oh oh so you can't you can't
it is a wrap for for you for a minute
Drake puts the call in yeah at least for
like five years Drake reached out to you
no but I met Drake twice how was that I
I that was crazy I was at a private
party one time in New York and I just
looked up and
Drake was reaching for my hand because
somebody that know Drake is on my label
and they was like this is and I'm like
damn this Drake he just walk around here
just like he normal for sure for sure
you walk around here like ignore him
within the second time was at his
private party for Super Bowl at
at um Dave and Buster's oh yeah he has
those that was Drake is an interesting
guy was that in Arizona yeah yeah in
Chandler or in uh yeah yeah in uh I know
where it was in the the Dave and Busters
outside
it's the outside mall in AZ
he's so hard for that I ain't gonna lie